all right welcome to another ideas that
matter conversation I have here somebody
I've been very much looking forward to
chatting with uh in part because of the
sort of work that she does and some of
the interesting positions that she's
developing in those works so this is
Krista Thomason who is an associate
professor of philosophy at Swarthmore
um she has two books and we're going to
talk a lot about the book that isn't yet
in anybody's hands but but hopefully
will be soon and that is Dancing with
the Devil why bad feelings make life
good so that already in the title quite
an ambitious and controversial claim
that we'll get into but she's also
published in 2018 naked the Dark Side of
Shame and moral life she's also
published a lot of Articles and
encyclopedia entries book reviews book
chapters and and um so we're going to be
talking a lot about emotion but I think
we'll probably spill over into other
areas and I should mention that you have
in your bio three things that um I I
found particularly
um intriguing in part because I I share
in them so you list yourself as being a
metal head a sports nut and a home chef
and I mean so I'll ask then this is sort
of trivia but like were you a metal
headset's childhood did you get into it
uh because somebody introduced you to it
um with the emotions I think absolutely
yeah yeah no so I started listening to
heavy metal when I was in college
actually and um you know occasionally
your rotten ex-boyfriends do you a favor
uh and so it was a rotten ex-boyfriend
who who introduced me to to metal
um my the first one that I bought the
first CD that I bought that was sort of
mine was a Jews priest screaming for
vengeance and it was oh it was like a
revelation it was amazing and I bought
it completely on a whim totally on a
whim I was like I don't know what this
is I've never heard of this before let
me see what's going on with this uh and
I listened to it and that it was kind of
it it was it it was they were my intro
and then they were also they became my
my favorite my very favorite of all time
you know you picked something like right
in the heart of what we call a classic
or now they call it traditional heavy
metal which I suppose makes sense
because you know its Origins is decades
and decades back
um but that's yeah that's a great album
and great band
um there was actually a big Twitter
controversy in one of those post sites
recently about that very album you know
is it number one some people oh no it
sucks compared to this one oh yeah yeah
there's some controversies in in sort of
priest fandom about you know which were
the ones that like everybody should like
and oh yeah you know I know we this
friend of mine who's a guitar professor
at Berkeley School of Music we had a
classic metal class for a while when
before we got too busy and we did one
session on um the best albums by classic
bands so we picked Iron Maiden uh Dio uh
Motorhead Judas Priest and then I think
accept we probably should have picked
the Scorpions instead but because they
have a you know wider catalog but it's
interesting painkiller dominated in the
polls because we ran a bunch
and I think the reason was I mean I
considered it a good album but I don't
think it's as good as screaming for
vengeance or Defenders of the faith or
my favorite sin after sin but it's good
I pegged you as a sin after saying oh
did you I did that would be very
interesting so let me just tell you this
and then you can tell me how you came to
that
so I I think that there's just so many
fans it's sort of like um that that you
know
um voting uh not the kind that we have
but like sort of it's a little bit like
ranked Choice voting you know there's
just too many people who really really
like painkiller for the other albums to
get much traction even if they get a lot
of votes they're splitting it among
themselves as opposed to like the the
painkiller right people so how would you
pick me as a sin after sin guy so so
this may be this is pretty surface level
judgment but the the folks who tend to
be like really hardcore and really
really into the genre and really
knowledgeable about the genre tend to be
sent after send people
oh interesting but yeah that's just been
my experience it's been like the the
more knowledgeable you are about the
genre as a whole the more likely I think
after sin tends to be your album
so this would be a good segue into
raising a question
um so you're doing a lot of work in
philosophy of emotion but in a whole
bunch of Allied areas as well
and you know very often you tell me
whether this is the case for you we will
get people who will say well what you're
doing really isn't scientific
um you know you need to be like looking
at at Psychology and psychology is a hot
mess by itself uh we could talk about
that in a bit but um you know what
you're talking about is going by a sort
of hunch but it's not just like a I've
got this you know loosey-goosey
intuition it's not based on anything
whatsoever
and I think that um when we're talking
about the emotions in particular
so part of that is affective right but
it's also cognitive it's not it's not
just a gut feeling or something like
that but when we're thinking about our
our emotions and other people's emotions
um we often do have to rely on these
sorts of hunches or you know inference
to the best explanation or abductive
leaps or stuff like that I mean do you
do you see that as something important
yeah absolutely and this is something I
get
um I actually get criticized for quite a
bit in my work um particularly by I
think other philosophers who are a
little bit more
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna say empirically but
I mean that in kind of a narrow sense
like who are who think that it's really
important that if you're going to talk
about emotions you really need to be up
on sort of the latest psychology
research Neuroscience research Etc
um so I what's funny about this is I
feel like people don't remember this
conversation that Aristotle has in
dayanama where he talks specifically
about this and he says there are really
two different ways that you could study
emotions there's a a way that you could
study them that he refers to as a pro
the approach of the student of dialectic
and then there's the approach of what he
calls the student of nature
and he describes both of those positions
and he says look the student of
dialectic is going to be the person who
thinks about anger and talks about the
reasons that you feel it and what you
tend to do with it and that sort of
stuff and then the student of nature is
going to talk about anger in a natural
way they're going to describe it as the
boiling of the blood around the heart
right that's my which is like that's
very metal all by itself
um so and then he and he just sort of
says these are two different ways of
understanding something I'm gonna go
with the student of nature because
that's what I'm interested in but that's
it he doesn't argue that the student of
nature is the only way to understand it
or even the best way to understand it he
just says that's a way of understanding
it so in the book I sort of set this up
and say that's a way to understand
emotions but here's another way to
understand emotions we're talking about
our experiences of them and our
relationships to them and that those
kinds of questions are not easily
addressed by getting up to speed on the
latest psychological or neurobiological
research on emotions they're better
understood from a kind of traditional
humanist perspective right again what
Aristotle calls the collecting of indoxa
reading people who have thought really
hard about this kind of stuff in the
past and kind of getting a sense of what
the various landscape is of the
positions that are out there and then
you know testing them using your own
methods and thinking to yourself like is
this the best way to describe this are
there counter examples that I can come
up with and I think what's funny about
that is I think those of us who are more
kind of humanistically inclined or
historically inclined philosophers we
don't tend to sort of highlight that as
a methodology as though that that is
kind of what we do right and that's and
and if it was good enough for Arizona
why isn't it good enough for us
you know what I found um much earlier in
my career when I was in places where it
was mostly analytics is I could get away
with
um describing what I was doing and it's
very similar to what you're talking
about just by calling it by the term
hermeneutic because they had heard it
they knew it was something it wasn't the
weird wacky you know Continental stuff
and I was doing history or philosophy
essentially you know
um and they then they would leave me
alone they'd be like I guess I guess
that's a valid way of going about it
exactly it's incredible if you just sort
of like give it a name suddenly people
are happy
yeah I mean there there could be a whole
discussion about that but I do want to
go back to something that I was going to
ask you about
um so you know we've got this vast field
of psychology and then you know it leads
over into other things as well you
mentioned uh neuroscience and you know
one of the things that I discovered when
I was doing a lot of work on on anger
was that when it comes to the emotions
there's no consensus in psychology as a
field about like how many emotions there
are how they work which ones are primary
and it sort of mirrors or models what
went on in the history of philosophy I
mean we've got so if we take Aristotle
and you know we get Beyond just the
rhetoric classification because there's
other emotions like grief you know
pothos that get discussed in the nick of
McKay and ethics
and we just put it side by side with say
the stoics right we've already got two
very different theories of emotions and
two different valuations so then we can
add others in
um and it seems to me like people will
appeal to like capital S science or
Capital psychology and
I do see this a lot in in educational
literature that deals with the emotions
um and it doesn't seem like they get
that there isn't any
single agreed upon approach to to rely
upon so I mean you could say well that's
a bad thing we're not making progress
like we ought to be but we've got a lot
of experience with that philosophy right
yeah I mean could we also take that as a
good thing and say well we can be
pluralistic we can draw on what we want
to we don't have to be wedded to one
single
model or Theory that's out there yeah
absolutely yeah I'm not I I find myself
actually quite confused about why it is
that people sort of appeal to this like
you say capital S science or Capital
psychology especially
um when you actually start looking at
the literature I feel like I feel like
so much of that attitude comes from
people who may not have sat down and
really started to read it
um and I tell you I to give a plug to
Lisa Feldman Barrett's book on um I
forget the name of it got it's I can't
believe it blanked on it but uh it's
about she sort of calls into question
this whole idea about there being basic
emotions right which is supposed to be a
staple of psychological literature on
emotions and I remember reading her book
and thinking well man if if one of the
like pillars of emotional research in
Psychology is actually kind of Up For
Debate and she does all these really
complicated studies to sort of show that
you know the the research that was done
to support the thesis if you tweet those
studies the the research just falls
apart and I thought well gosh this is
they're having the same scholarly
debates that philosophers are having
right so yeah I think that's fine I like
let them do their thing with their
methodology and and run the test and run
the experiments that's great it's a it
you know it's a living breathing
discipline in the same way that
philosophy is a living breathing
discipline what I what I really kind of
want to resist is this idea that sort of
they're they've got the right way of
studying it and that what we do is
somehow always beholden to what they're
doing and that it's not just sort of two
different ways of understanding the same
thing or that we might be interested in
very different kinds of questions
um and that that's fine like so I want
to kind of pluralism where I feel like
there's a lot of people who want no no
psychology has got to be on top and
philosophy has just got to be you know
waiting for the answers from the lab
coats and that's the that's the attitude
that I want to resist
yeah I mean philosophy of emotion first
off philosophers were around doing it
before the psychologist came out as a
separate discipline you know just a few
centuries ago but it seems like uh why
should they get to
claim that space over everybody else I
mean sometimes they it's just sort of
assertion well we're the ones I mean
absolutely an analogy to this would be
sart
um sort of ruining existentialism for
everybody else by defining what it is
you know yeah yeah and then other people
being like well if that's what you say
it is then I guess I'm not an
existentialist study
um yeah
so let's come back to the the um new
book
um one of the things we were going to
talk about was the the writing process
yeah and maybe before we get into like
bad feelings let's talk about that I
mean I'm sure some will come up along
the way because writing is
um I mean I don't know I won't speak for
you on this but as somebody who's done
some writing myself it can be a very
frustrating
anxiety provoking process right
absolutely absolutely yeah it's um when
I came up with the idea of sort of
talking a bit more about the writing
process I sort of thought you know we
don't do that enough Even in our kind of
regular professional lives we're not
very upfront and honest about how we go
about doing this uh and I think it's and
that I think feeds into a certain kind
of mystery that people have about I
can't tell you the number of people who
have asked me well like what's it like
to do philosophy research what does that
even mean to do philosophy research
right and so I thought you know the
writing pulling back be curtain a little
bit on the writing process would in some
sense help answer that question too
um but yeah so I so in some sense I was
like super lucky because I did most of
the book while I was on sabbatical I had
a wonderful fellowship with the National
Humanities Center so I was researching
full-time and that was great uh this is
the first time I've written a trade book
so this book is for the public it is not
for philosophers I hope philosophers
read it and like it
um I have my doubts that you you know
how we are I'm preparing myself for lots
of criticism here
um but I but my real goal in the book
was to give anybody who wants to think
about their negative emotions maybe a
little bit differently a way to do that
so writing learning how to write a trade
book that was really tough really tough
and I need so how did you learn how to
do that help help from people so I had
readers who were just my friends people
who you know somebody who's uh who may
may have gone to college but didn't
study philosophy uh people who were just
the kind of folks who want to read a
book who might be curious and interested
but who have no expertise whatsoever and
my beloved husband who is a fiction
writer who is very good at wordcraft
read every draft I think that I gave him
because he was and he was looking at it
from like that perspective so the actual
word craft perspective and it's not it
would not be and my fellows at the
national Humanity Center who read drafts
for me who are not necessarily
philosophers or who talked with me about
my ideas
that all that helped me be able to
present it to someone who's not an
expert but that I would never have been
successful at that if I didn't have that
help
so that's sort of on the like
have to to finish end of it
um and so I'm gonna you know facetiously
bring up one of those questions that
anybody who's a creative gets where do
you get your ideas from so there has to
be an initial motivation absolutely what
was that for this book yeah so it really
sprang out of my first book so my first
book is on shame and
um the the motivation behind the first
book was I you know I started reading a
lot of philosophical literature on shame
and and the reason this is the reason
that the book has that title I started
reading in all of these different
um examples of the kinds of cases that
people come up with with shame and it's
things like in expressions of
ingratitude and you know minor uh minor
transgressions of various kinds and I
remember reading all that literature and
saying to myself yeah yeah yeah but
where are all the naked people
okay meaning there's a there's a section
of cases of shame that don't really fit
with this certain kind of conception
that you find in the philosophical
literature where shame is kind of
already moralized and it's about moral
failings right but there's lots of cases
of shame that are not about moral
failings and so what happens if we stop
centering the moral cases and we start
centering these other cases what would
we discover about shame would we would
we come up with a different conception
of Shame and that doing that work made
me start thinking about the relationship
we have to our negative emotions in
general and I think I think that our
relationship with our negative emotions
inside philosophy and outside philosophy
is fraught
um and so once I started thinking about
that I started thinking there's work to
do on negative emotions in general so I
started doing more philosophical work
anger contempts by that sort of stuff
and then I got to the point where I
thought you know
when you just listen to people talk
about their negative emotions
uh they're so
scared of them for the most part right
yeah and so resistant to them and even
if you you know something terrible
happens to you and you are really
mourning or you're really angry uh
people are so quick to try to correct
your feelings and and it was that
impulse that got me going on a more
popular version of the work that I had
been doing in philosophy because I
thought you know I think other people
people out there who are just who just
want to think about this I think they
need something they need some other
voice in the mix that's saying you know
maybe these bad feelings aren't so bad
after all
it's interesting because
um in the sort of like
philosophy is a way of life you know
broad popular philosophy where people
are taking
um you know aristotelianism or stoicism
or stuff like that
um that Dynamic that you're talking
about happens all the time where people
are in some respect I mean the stomach
would say well you're not made to feel
it because you know you decide whether
you take that on or not but the the
overall tenor is okay we've got these
negative emotions
um you'd do better not to feel them
let's try to get through this as quickly
as possible so you can just feel the
good emotions and and you know with
Aristotle we've got something a bit
different you know it's it's less about
well off or on and more like well how
are you feeling this this anger or how
are you feeling
um this well I mean it's interesting
because with Aristotle right no good
amount of Shame right exactly exactly
um yeah so so we get that and and I
think that's that's a very important
thing to say and I'm constantly in like
groups having to say okay we're not
going to repress our emotions we're not
going to like put them aside we actually
need to look at why you feel anxious and
what that's coming from and then once
you understand it you can you can work
through it
um and then you see similar things in
like positive psychology you want to
have a ponderance of positive over
negative emotions and we'll do a lot of
like journaling and trying to you know
give affirmations to ourselves to change
our our mindset on stuff yeah and I want
to endorse like negative emotions
totally uh like some wild romantic
saying you know they're all great you
know they reveal being to me or
something because some of them are you
know we could say really damaging or
pathological but there has to be a lot
more scope for that and you know grief
is a a great example I you know I'm not
a stoic I'm an Eclectic but I do a lot
of things in stoic circles
and you know my close companion cat
sassy died a year and a half ago and the
animal I've been closest to in in my
life and you know I wrote some things
about grief and I got some some Flack
from people who are like you're not
supposed to be writing about that you're
supposed to be processing it and getting
over it right away and you know I was
like
first of all it's not stoic to actually
tell other people what it is to be a
stoic especially if you don't know what
you're talking about
um but you know uh what makes you think
you should jump in here and and uh that
you know somehow grief by itself and
they'll be like well you know um it's
one of those four basic bad emotions you
know it's under Lupe uh pain and you
know I was like well so much the worst
for stoicism then right on that issue
but I wanted to go back to um so you've
got this piece alienated emotions and
self-knowledge and this seems
core to what you're talking about is
your motivation
um and I I'll mention to anybody who's
watching or listening you can actually
access this on on uh Krista Toms
thomason's website
um so you can read it for yourself and
and see what she's saying here but it
seems to me so first of all what is an
alienated emotion that's a technical
term that you've got and then how does
it figure into this broader like let's
reclaim some of the space of negative
emotions that you were talking about
yeah yeah so I got really interested in
alienated emotions because of uh an
emotional what I call an emotional
instant in my own life
um so uh so I start this is in the piece
so I start off with this story about
um uh so I had a pet mouse when I was
kid uh never in a million years thought
of myself as somebody who was afraid of
mice had no like you know other people
would sort of freak out about them and I
was like I would hold my pet mouse I
loved her dearly and you know we had the
whole relation and everything
um when I'm an adult tonight and I live
in my first house I hear noises in the
kitchen at night and so I walk into the
kitchen I'm awake and I because I'm in
graduate school and I'm always awake at
night
um so I walk into the kitchen at night I
flip on the light trying to see what's
going on and a Mouse runs across my foot
in my kitchen and I absolutely lose my
mind with fear I mean not just like ah
it's
screaming uncontrollably
um I Dash in this like Mad Dash over to
the mat that's in front of the sink in
my kitchen and I stand there screaming
absolutely uncontrollably wake my
husband up he has to come down the
hallway and I actually am paralyzed with
fears the only time in my life I have
ever literally been paralyzed with fear
oh interesting and he has to like walk
me physically out of the kitchen
and I just completely lose my mind so I
am baffled by this reaction absolutely
truly baffled by this reaction nothing
in my past has predicted that this is
how I would have reacted in this
situation and it wasn't just a little
bit of fear it was an enormous amount of
fear yeah so the impetus for the paper
was about what do you do when you have
an experience like that what do you do
when you experience an emotion that is
surprising that is um in some sense
unwelcome to you that is uh something
that you didn't expect at all and that
there's and then in some sense feels
very contrasting to how you've seen
yourself to your own self-conception
what do you do about those emotions
and the line that I end up taking in the
paper is that I think it's a mistake to
dismiss them I think that's a very easy
and understandable thing I think it's
very I think anybody I've talked to
about the mouse incident has always said
well it was the middle of the night and
you're only you're heightened anyway and
the mouse scared you and you know that's
a very easy thing but to me that doesn't
quite represent sort of the honesty or
the reality of the situation which is
that look I really had this like I'm I'm
troubled by it I'm troubled still by the
reaction that I had and it sort of has
changed in some sense how I see myself
and so that I feel like I actually think
that's okay it's okay for us to treat
these emotions so alienated emotions are
the emotions that are surprising
contrasting to your self-image
um in some sense unwelcome emotions that
you experience that you don't expect
yourself to have uh I just think it's a
mistake to dismiss them in part because
I am committed to the view that your
emotions tell you stuff
we'll tell you stuff about the world
they also tell you stuff about you and
to tell you stuff about your relations
to other people sometimes they tell you
things that you don't already know
and so that is what or want to know or
want to know
and so if that's if I'm committed to
that view then I have to sort of take
seriously emotions like alienated
emotions because I I act I absolutely am
committed to the view that your
alienated emotion might be right and
your self-conception and the judgments
that you've made about who you think you
are they might be wrong
and an alienated emotion through
something like you know good
Psychotherapy because there's lots of
bad Psychotherapy out there or you know
think about virtue ethics not as just a
moralizing work but as like you know
deciding to deliberately work on your
your character or I don't know spiritual
direction or any of these other things
where you're making advances can an
alienated emotion cease to be alienated
and become integrated within your
self-understanding and your sort of
long-term Narrative of who you are yeah
I do think that's possible right and I
think so for me what's and I don't have
anything written on this and I'm still
My Views about it are still in sort of
it's the infancy stage but I'm really
interested in this question of like what
Charles Taylor calls self-interpretation
and how do you do that well and how you
do that without without self-deception
with honesty but also you know in all
sorts of like how how does that go how
does that go well and I think when
you're dealing with alienated emotions
it might look you don't all you don't
know ahead of time when you experience
it you don't know ahead of time what's
going to happen with the emotion yeah it
could remain alienated you could end up
sort of altering your self-conception in
a way like I could come to decide you
know what actually I am afraid of mice I
I and maybe and that maybe didn't used
to be true about me but it's clearly
true about me now and so I change based
on this experience I sort of changed the
way that I understand myself and now I
say well I know maybe I am a person
who's afraid of afraid of mice
um or maybe I sort of exist in this uh
state of ambivalence where I'm not
totally sure and I don't really know
what to do and and I don't necessarily
rush to kind of settle the question yeah
I mean it would be tempting to write off
um
these sort of experiences
in two different ways you know depending
on whether you believe in a Crosshair or
not I'm a firm believer that across yeah
which is lack or loss of self-control
right it's a real thing I mean I've
experienced it myself people who claim
that it doesn't exist they're almost
like on a different planet right I'm
concerned so I mean it would be tempting
to say oh well you know it's just one
incident
um normally I'm this way but everybody
has has failures or you could um go like
this you know the socratic stoic Road
it's actually a mafia it's a lack of
proper knowledge or something like that
and it seems to me that I think you're
completely right about this that these
are things that we do have to think
about and make an effort to try to
understand and integrate rather than
just simply taking these easy strategies
of
which are offered to us of um writing
them off and I'm curious
um so I mean we could think of all sorts
of things like feeling a sort of
poignancy of grief over watching a movie
a clear fictional situation but it
somehow connects to us and we're like oh
I feel so sad right now and it doesn't
make sense why why am I crying or losing
our temper after we've been a really
mild person and then we blow up or you
know but could you have
um the thing that you're calling
alienated emotions could there also be
um cases where you're not feeling
something that you were feeling before
or you you think that you ought to feel
so you I don't know you're involved with
somebody in a romantic relationship and
then suddenly the feeling is gone and
you're like oh what's going on here
um I better figure out how to rekindle
this because I've made a commitment to
this relationship but it's it's suddenly
not there or yeah
I know not feeling anger when you
normally would
so is is the alienated just has to be
that it doesn't make sense to me
or
um characteristic or right that's a good
question so I'm not I don't know exactly
how technical I want to be with the
alienated emotions I I what I want to
maintain I think is the the element of
sort of unexpectedness or surprise so
you find yourself in a situation where
you expect yourself to feel a certain
way and you don't or you don't expect
yourself to feel a certain way and then
suddenly you do
um and I think that actually and the
reason I'm interested in this obviously
is because I think it happens more than
people realize that it happens and so
you end up with you know you're in all
sorts of situations where you think uh
you know on my wedding day I come from a
very long line of criers right very
emotional family lots and lots of criers
so I just assumed on my wedding day I'm
going to be in tears the entire day
incorrect I was cool as a cucumber I was
the only person in the entire situation
other than some of the guests who was
cool as a cucumber
um and I and that was completely
surprise surprising to me a welcome
surprise like right you but completely
surprising to me and I still don't have
an explanation for why I was that way
so that kind of experience I think is
actually like pretty familiar to people
yeah um and we also to your point about
sort of being in situations where you
think you should feel certain things
we are pretty bad about this I think we
tend to tell ourselves a lot of stories
about because we tend to be very
judgmental about our emotions and so we
tend to tell ourselves a lot of stories
about how we should feel in certain
circumstances
sometimes that's a reasonable criticism
it's not always though because there
have been you know how many of us have
been in romantic relationships where
um something is wrong and something is
missing but you are telling yourself
that everything seems everything should
be fine and and you should be happy and
why aren't you happy and so we will then
try to kind of force ourselves to start
you know you'll start talking yourself
into it and trying to talk yourself into
this emotion when in reality maybe there
is actually something wrong with your
situation and you're picking up on that
through your sort of emotional life but
you're not necessarily picking up on
that through your judgmental or your I'm
not going to say rational because I
don't like the Divide between rational
and emotional um but but you're you're
sort of like conscious judgmental life
so that goes right back to your new book
um what are so bad emotions right what
makes bad emotions or bad feelings
actually bad what are what are some of
the examples of
emotions that people feel they ought not
to feel that you want to say no no
there's some scope for this yeah so
there's a there's a pretty broad range
of what counts what might count as a bad
feeling
um in the book I kind of narrow it down
to the ones that I think people think of
as pretty morally questionable so
they're the ones that um I can't
remember who is it that makes this
distinction but there's a philosopher
who makes I believe it's uh Robert C
Roberts who makes the distinction
between sort of the um he heals them the
nasty emotions or it might be Robert
Solomon who calls them the nasty
emotions and the Nash the emotions are
the ones that um people really you'll
they'll judge themselves very harshly
for feeling it or they'll feel like
there's some uh you have a character
flaw maybe if you have these kinds of
emotions so the ones that I talk about
in the book specifically are anger
contempt um jealousy and envy Spite and
shot and freuda okay
yeah that's the I mean a lot of that
fits right into Aristotle quite nicely
you know
so
broadening it a little bit I mean
let's let's take something like grief
um from the perspective of say the
stoics it's always a bad thing I would
say there's probably you know quite a
few uh schools of psychology and
Psychotherapy that won't say well it's a
it's a bad thing it's a necessary thing
but you should process it and get
through it and you know leave it behind
you
um would that fit into this this schema
because you know if you um if you're
grieving somebody like you know I've
I've actually you know experienced a lot
of death and loss in my family life and
stuff like that and I'll go to people
who had a big loss and I'll say
um you know six months down the line a
year down the line when everybody wants
you to have gotten over this if you want
to reach out to me go ahead because I'll
I'll actually listen to you talk about
how you miss your mom or something like
that because most people want you to
like you know there's like a an orderly
thing maybe a month and then and then
you should be finished so would that fit
in with this
um you know bad feelings so this is so
that's this is where my my like as you
mentioned the wild Romantics earlier
this is for my wild romantic streak
comes out because I uh so I adore
Aristotle I I don't think this kind of
the vision of well right time right
place right proportion Etc
um I get how tempting that is I really
understand how tempting it is to sort of
be able to incorporate your emotions
that way and to manage them that way and
but I don't think it is actually
capturing how they really work
um and I also don't think it's capturing
the role that they ought to play in
their life so I'm not so can they can
they be tamed in this way can they be
managed the way that Aristotle and
Confucius in particular they were my two
guys who kind of represent this view
um can they I don't know that jury's
still out on how much we can how much
control we have
um I want to resist the idea that the
kind of relationship we should have
toward them is to manage them in that
way actually maybe we should have a
different relationship toward them
precisely the reasons that you say about
the grief could you say that like maybe
some of the time like in everyday stuff
we should be managing them and learning
how to integrate our affective and
cognitive side and you know be a decent
person in life you have the right kind
of responses right but that there should
be much more room for let's call it
unusual or extraordinary cases and and
rather than just saying okay we cut you
know we've got the limit here a well I
don't know a uh well integrated person
won't feel this sort of stuff I mean I
think what you're saying is no well
integrated person will feel this sort of
stuff because they're a human being
absolutely and they're subject to you
know a contingent World in which weird
things happen absolutely and then
figuring out how to you know
reincorporate these is important yeah so
this is so I think and I'm not sure I
think maybe sort of my vision of what
you know a good emotional life and what
like maybe Aristotle or confucius's
vision of a good emotional life I think
on the surface they might look the same
um I think the that that General picture
the sort of what I call the the kind of
Confucius or I call it the cultivated
emotion Saints in the book
um it's about cultivating your emotions
right and it's about it's not about
trying to get rid of them it's not about
trying to diminish the power that they
have it's about sort of like in
integrating them right into your life
and making them uh training them to sort
of be a part of a part of your life yeah
um what I think would be better in some
sense more true to the way emotions are
and the role that they should play is
actually to be to learn how to be
comfortable
with a part of you that you don't really
control
okay yeah so rather than trying rather
than trying to sort of tame them
integrate them make them kind of play A
Part yeah what would it look like
instead to have a certain kind of
perspective on your emotional life and
realize that because you're a human
being subject to all kinds of contingent
things that your emotional life is going
to be a complicated place and it's not
necessarily going to be something that
you actually can manage all the time or
even or even you know what and what
would that look like what would it look
like to actually be more comfortable
with having that kind of wild romantic
part of you
yeah and you know there couldn't be any
straight across the board set of rules
or procedures for that right because
because it is contingent so exactly
can't know whether this well
integrated grounded person who seems uh
to get through everything when they I
don't know will take grief again
um somebody dies and they're not really
that close to it suddenly this person is
crying at their desk exactly um yeah you
can't uh effectively predict that that
sort of thing so does that mean we're
always playing catch up then when it
comes to this
possibly
I mean can you say more about what you
mean by catch up well so you you know
you can't adequately prepare except in a
very general sense of being able to say
well you know let's not dismiss these
things for the weird
outlier kind of emotional events that
that we have or we see other people
having right yes and so I am a big
Advocate I think I think where I land on
this is so what can you do if if you're
if we're gonna if we're gonna say we're
gonna figure out how to live well with
the thing that we don't really control
or can't control fully so what does that
look like so I think there are two
things that that are going to be key for
this one we have got to work on
emotional honesty okay where that means
um you you have to get to know your
feelings and I use in the I talk about
this in the conclusion I use Thoreau
when Thoreau is kind of talking about
um the uh he has this great line in
higher laws where he's talking about
sort of these times in the woods where
he's he says I you know was raving like
a half star of town but he talks about
sort of getting to know the Wilderness
really getting to know it really
exploring it and not trying to sort of
take his preconceived notions about what
it is but actually living through it is
what allows him to kind of see it for
what it really is and to not really be
afraid of it anymore and so I think that
I think that's going to be really key
for living with our emotions in this way
is to really explore them to feel them
to be honest when they're there and not
necessarily and that's going to require
a lot I mean I actually don't think
we're particularly good at this so I
think this is going to require a lot of
work
um so so honestly emotional honesty and
really getting to know and understand
your emotions and being will able to
tell the difference let's say between
your frustration and your anger and
knowing what those feel like
um that's going to be one piece I think
the other piece and this is where when
we criticize people for being too
emotional I think oftentimes we're not
necessarily criticizing them for the
feelings I think what we're actually
criticizing them for is the the things
they care about that lie behind the
feelings
so I think mostly when we're talking
about people getting too angry or
something like that it's not so much the
anger that we're mad about it's that
they don't have a sense of proportion
right or a sense of like what's
significant and what's not or a sense of
perspective like deal you know
understand that there are some things
that are big and some things that are
small but that itself that's not really
an emotional thing exactly that's just
and I don't know how to teach someone to
have perspective but but I think that's
usually when we're criticizing that's
what we're criticizing and so if that's
right then there's like some set of
other kinds of
um virtues I'm gonna call them that we
can develop that are not that are not
necessarily taming our emotional lives
but that are kind of setting ourselves
up in to to to avoid the kinds of
criticisms that we usually Lodge at the
emotional person yeah I mean from a
traditional virtue ethics perspective
whether it's like you know platonic
Aristotelian or stoic or pick whatever
you want
um I think a lot of people's response
would be well that's where fronasis
comes in you know yeah
tells you what to do and all that but
that that seems kind of wrong
I mean I'm I'm more attracted to the
idea that I I think I just heard you
articulate that we need plural
um and we won't even say whether they're
intellectual or moral virtues they're
just habitus is there something that we
build up in ourselves that give us a
capacity for discernment and making good
judgments
um and you know it's it's um
it's difficult to classify those I mean
the Temptation is to say well they all
just fall under one big thing right that
that can't be right yeah I'm a much more
I I anytime anybody starts talking about
sort of unity and integration and you
know all that I just I'm like well not
so much of the virtues it's just I I
feel like people are very philosophers
in particular are very into this idea
you have to be whole and you have to be
not conflicted and you have to be
integrated and all the parts have to
sing beautifully together and I think
I'm just not attracted to them yeah I'm
much more attracted to a kind of
fragmented
um you know we got to be okay with being
broken and that's okay we can still be
all right and be broken it doesn't have
to be the push isn't always to sort of
make sure that there's perfect Inner
Harmony all of the time I'll I'll go off
on a little rant at this point so when
somebody like invokes things like the
thesis of the unity have the virtues my
eyes kind of glaze over and I quit
paying attention to them just like when
they're like you know Aristotle's
function argument I'm like well that's
not in the text you know right right and
the text is a lot more complicated and
fragmentary you know and and the idea of
somebody who actually whatever list of
Virtues we've got the idea of somebody
who actually possesses all of them to me
I'm like I've never seen a human being
remotely like that I'm much more
attracted to uh thinkers like you know
nietza who thinks that the virtues war
against each other absolutely or you
know John Cassian actually has a really
funny thing to say about this in I think
it's in early on in the institutes he
says listen the best you can have is
like one virtue
and he and he's so he's got a
theological perspective he's like how
can you have a Unity of the virtues only
in this super special guy Christ being
and I don't want to be as pessimistic as
him and say you can only cultivate one
single virtue but I mean the idea that
you're going to
you know first of all that that well if
you got one you got them all you know
that that seems like so empirically uh
uh obviously wrong you know right right
right and then you're like well who the
hell are they who who are these people
theorizing who are we talking about
exactly yeah that has always been my and
this is as you can imagine this is one
of my sort of Bones to pick with
Nussbaum is that there's a kind of right
there's a um the whole day which
exemplars are we talking about and when
you're telling me that the people you're
talking about are Christ and like Martin
Luther King Jr which is I'm not even
sure that that's an accurate picture of
Martin Luther King Jr but okay
um you know maybe that and Gandhi okay
listen I think we need to like have a
conversation about what we're looking
for in our more if are they are your
emotional exemplars
I think maybe we need to have a little
conversation about what our expectations
are
so this is a great segue into this
review that you have which is much more
than a book review it's a very it's it's
a critical book review
of uh nusbaum's recent that makes it
sound so fancy well I mean that's that's
the genre yeah that's true so I mean you
saw you do the traditional book review
thing chapter one chapter two chapter
three and you don't like pull out any
criticisms at those points and then more
than half of the the piece is saying I
think she got this wrong I mean she's
right about this but she also tweaked
this in the wrong direction and here's
some assumptions that she made yeah I I
use this book as a textbook for a class
that I teach a semester-long class on
anger at Marquette University that's
part of their core thing so I'm not
teaching it to philosophy people I'm
teaching it to like Juniors and seniors
who generally they've had like a
philosophy class and they're not
particularly interested in all right but
everybody's interested in anger and I
picked the book having read it before
and having some problems of my own with
with no spell
um I I was like well this could at least
provide some structure right but
um I I think I may actually the next
time that I get to teach this class I
may actually
um include this particular book review
within the uh the materials for the
class because there's so many places
where you're like okay she's right about
this here's where the Assumption goes
wrong
um and so I mean I don't want to like
just pick on no spell maybe we can widen
this what what do you yeah you think are
some of the the and it doesn't have to
just be anger some of the things you're
pointing out really figure into broader
uh misconceptions of emotions that
people are using yeah um what would you
say are some of the most important ones
yeah so I think there's a there's a
couple
um there are two that I really tackle
sort of head on in the book so one is is
again the the position that I think is
sort of associated with no spam and
again I you know I should say it just as
an aside I should say you know the
reason that those of us who do
contemporary work and emotions are here
is in part because of her and her early
work is like fantastic and yeah you know
so I can only be so critical but um but
I can definitely make it critical uh
that there is so there so there's this
assumption that sort of negative
emotions are something like
fundamentally irrational they are they
are you know
um they're always mistaken they're
always there's something anytime you're
feeling them you're you're making some
kind of rational mistake or who knows
right there that there are there are
these kind of irrational forces and and
you see this view not just in a spawn
but in other people right there's this
kind of view about negative emotions as
um you know this angry irrational forces
that are part of our human nature
because we're flawed or something like
that and they're there to torture us and
we are you know we would do our best if
we figured out how to be better humans
how to get rid of that part of ourselves
um and this is uh what the this is one
of the um one of the things I talk about
in the book is this aspiration to what I
call emotional sainthood so I think
there's I think this is a very powerful
ideal that people hold whether they
realize it or not and it's this it's
this kind of view that all things
considered it would be better if human
beings did not have negative emotions
and there are lots of people who will
say yes and that would be good and we
should strive for it and I think those
are the folks who who hold up like
Christ for example or these kind of
exemplars of we have to transcend we
have to transform our human nature in
order to do this and that that would be
better but people don't do it because
it's super hard
and people are flawed and lazy and so
they just don't do it
um and then I think there's another way
of responding to emotional sainthood
which is to say well look no no no it's
that's not attainable for us look that's
not possible it's not possible for us to
get rid of all these negative emotions
the best we can manage is to just you
know lessen their influence on us or or
manage them in the right kinds of ways
this is the kind of like Aristotle
confusion sort of view or or you know
train ourselves to like get our
gratitude journal and start doing the
Gratitude Journal right and sort of like
that's gonna train but it would still be
so just you know it we can't get rid of
them but manage them right or feel them
as little you know like less even less
would be better so a little bit of
sainthood goes a long way
and what I want to do is get rid of the
aspiration okay like it's not like let's
don't aspire to emotional statehood
don't don't look at emotional sainthood
and say that's the best version of a
human life
think to yourself instead no no no
you you can have a good human life and
that negative emotions not in spite of
your negative emotions but the negative
motions are an integral part of your
good human life
they're not obstacles to living well
they're part of what it means to live
well but not all negative emotions right
whether we're talking in the broad like
classes of them uh or in particular
instances we still do want to have you
know if I see somebody who I don't know
let's so I've I've had friends who've
had like terrible relationships over and
over and over again and they choose the
wrong person and they stay in them too
long and some of them are my family
members I'm just not going to say
anything no name yeah and I think we all
know people like that right and you
could be like you know you ask them what
are you doing there and they're like oh
I I just you know I'm afraid of uh being
alone which that would be a negative
emotion or
um I love the thrill that I get when I'm
with the the screwed up person
um some of these you could say Okay
um
I would say some of this could be okay
like you're trying this stuff out but
let's not do this the rest of your life
you know so how do we differentiate
between
the the negative or bad emotions that
we've made some room for legitimate room
and then ones where we're like no this
this really is damaging to the the
person and their relationships we we
ought to say don't be like that without
telling them to be a saint right right
I'm so glad you asked that so this is
yeah so this is the part where I think
my view starts to get a little
challenging so I
um I am actually comfortable making room
for even those emotions okay and the
reason I am comfortable with that is
because I think we mistakenly pin the
trouble on the emotions themselves
and I think actually more often than not
what's happening is that people are
there's a there's a different thing
people are doing and that what ends up
happening is the trouble starts when we
start what I this is the in an
incredibly technical term that I use
when we start doing something with our
feelings okay and doing something looks
a lot of different ways right so and
it's in contrast to just feel the damn
thing
so we do all sorts of things with our
emotions my favorite example of this is
Envy right Envy comes with an enormous
Suite of coping mechanisms and I think
most of the time what's happening is the
trouble starts with the coping
mechanisms not the feeling and the
reason we start doing bad coping
mechanisms is because we are allergic to
just sitting there and going I feel Envy
right now yeah that hurts we don't like
that it makes us squirm and because we
are like so resistant to just
experiencing the negativity we start
trying to take that negativity and do
something with it so that's where you
get the crappy coping mechanisms like I
envy my neighbor's new car gonna go grab
the baseball bat from my garage and
solve this problem right now yeah by
bashing in the headlights but it's also
where you get the like hustle culture
grind set attitude where people start
going well do you envy that person for
their new car well then I'm going to use
that as motivation to save more money so
that I can too can get right and and we
what we are absolutely allergic to is
just going gosh I'm so envious of that
car
full stop yeah and just experiencing the
negativity I think most of the time when
emotions when we're pinning when we're
saying that negative emotion is causing
trouble what we're actually seeing is
that person does not know how to just
feel that thing and so they are doing
all kinds of stuff in response to that
feeling that is causing all manner of
issues so some of that could be from
just ignorance or inexperience right or
or bad models show other people handle
that but
I mean we could talk about and I I I
never want to use the word meta because
it winds up spiraling off into Meta Meta
Meta but right right I mean we could
talk about a a fear of One's Own
emotions exactly right so a fear to
linger in Anger that you can't do
anything with absolutely absolutely and
I think that's that is a hundred percent
part of this that's there's a big layer
of of Judgment of fear because if you
think about it look we don't we haven't
hatched from eggs here we have existed
in a culture particularly those of us
who grew up in the U.S that are that is
just so resistant to negativity right
positivity and the power of positive
thinking and positive emotions and all
that stuff that's what I was in the
water particularly in the U.S and we are
very uncomfortable with negativity and
so we have built up layers and layers
and layers of judgment about those
feelings is so you start to feel envy
and all the immediately you start
jumping to I'm a bad person
um people are going to judge me if I
keep feeling this it's going to eat me
up from the inside right notice this is
what I call the emotion double standard
actually we say all kinds of things
about negative emotions that we never
say about positive emotions no one ever
says to you oh God your joy is going to
eat you up from the inside no one ever
says to you you need to process your joy
and then move on
people do with I I can do that kind of
counter example
um but it it's uh narrow in its scope so
when somebody takes joy and maybe some
other uh emotions as well so a desire
things like that and it's in something
that's felt to be too unserious or
trivial or something like that so
fandoms right oh interesting now I'm not
a fan so I I don't I'm not into like
superhero movies right yeah yeah the
whole Marvel Universe but there are
people who really really geek out about
that right and
um you know they get quite invested in
it and a new movie comes out and they're
like oh my God I'm gonna go to the
theater and see this this could be an
amazing experience and stuff like that
and then we look at them and we're like
oh look at what what a geek that person
is you know it's so silly you know real
problems in the world you know or you
should be appreciating fine movies yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and you know with music right so I'm
sure is a fellow Metal Head you probably
ran into dismissive people who are
absolutely real music
oh yeah as a matter of fact I'll tell
you a funny story just real quick so
when I was 16 years old I got in a lot
of trouble I actually became a ward of
the court and I was placed in juvenile
detention center and they let us do like
field trips
and there was a girl on this this field
trip and she was like uh you know into
classical music very you know uh sort of
I don't know what she was in for she
must have done something wrong but she
she kind of hit her nose to me here and
um I was you know typical I had long
hair and you know looked kind of kind of
uh
sketchy and we're sitting there in the
car and I I knew something about music
so I was like you know heavy metal has a
lot in common with classical and she
turned to me with this like absolute
image of contempt and she said who
rattled your cage you know you're an ape
you know oh and then she didn't talk to
me after that and I was like very taken
it back wow
um but you know that's sort of like oh
the things that you silly people enjoy
so maybe maybe there is something like
that or yeah I suppose like positive
emotions
love would be another one where like
you're bestowing love on somebody
Unworthy of your love when you should be
giving it to somebody better like right
take the cat thing right yeah yeah your
pet mouse I don't know so people will be
like you know you shouldn't be that
attached to it it's just a pet yeah
exactly
[Music]
um why aren't you being this loving too
I don't know your students or something
right right and so I guess I would want
to know is the criticism that we're
making there is the criticism of the
emotion or is the criticism like what
the what the value is that's lying
behind it right so are we criticizing
people because they care about the wrong
things yeah so it's like oh you
shouldn't care about that but what we
are doing is in making that criticism
we're recognizing that the emotion that
you have toward that thing is an
expression of your care yeah right it's
like oh the reason that you take so much
joy in that Marvel movie is because you
really like it but you're investing too
much time in it I think there has to
either be a comparison you're you're
enjoying you're loving this thing too
much when you should be doing this thing
over here
or it could be just something where the
person themselves is being dismissed for
being
um
part of a class of unserious people yeah
that's yeah and I think with heavy metal
in particular that there's very much
sort of a class there's some class stuff
that's kind of like tied up in this
right because it's you know classical
music is coded upper class right right
the heavy metal is coded lower class
yeah
yeah well that's quite quite interesting
so Envy is uh a good one for that I mean
could there be you mentioned contempt
and I imagine what you mean by that is
something like the classic kind of
fronasis you know looking down upon yeah
how would that be a useful or
appropriate emotional response yeah
that's a good question so
I think we uh I think one of the things
that we do in with negative emotions is
uh we tend to focus on what I call the
extreme cases so again back to Envy we
look at Iago from Shakespeare and we go
wow that's Envy right like that and so
we what we don't do is look at the very
boring mundane typical kind of cases of
Envy in our like very normal human
social life
um if we're if we kind of take and I
think contempt is like so very much
suffers from this because we we look at
contempt and we think oh that's you know
you're dehumanizing someone right when
you're talking about contempt right and
and so that I want to go like okay time
out
um think about exercise culture I'm a
runner okay I do yoga
um here's the thing you sometimes hear
when you're like when I first started
out running I would go and I would go on
like online running forums to kind of
get support and tips and that sort of
stuff and one of the things you would
very frequently see is well even if
you're a brand new Runner and you don't
know what you're doing you're still
lapping everyone who's on the couch
which is okay it's funny and humorous
and silly motivation yeah but what is it
what's the communication there right
yeah there you're better than somebody
else
same thing happened in yoga like at the
contempt mild it's mild I think we don't
even look at that as contempt because
it's so mild right but at the end of the
day contempt is really about looking
down on someone it's looking it's going
like well I'm not like that that is
that's contempt in its kind of mundane
version
um I know is that like really morally
attractive well I'm not defending
negative emotions because they're all
morally attractive like that's not my
point my point is sort of defend them in
at their place in our lives in general
even when we're not thinking about sort
of virtue so is contempt virtuous no
contempt's not virtuous but it is a part
of
um self-building so when you are and we
all go through this when you are in
stages in your life where you feel shaky
and you don't really know am I making
like when you become a runner am I
making progress am I kind of floundering
here what am I doing I sort of need to
look around and kind of compare myself
to people and say well I'm not I'm
definitely not as good as other people
but I'm maybe not so bad as those people
so like maybe I'm doing okay that I
think is I pretty harmless and I think
with this thing we do all the time where
we get into trouble is kind of using
those moments to sort of assure
ourselves that we're never going to be
on the wrong end of the comparison right
so I mean look there's plenty trust me
as a runner who is not fast like there
are plenty of people who have used me
and gone I'm not like her you know and
that and I gotta be aware of that at the
same time I'm doing it to the people who
are behind me and yeah like eventually
you don't want to sort of stay there and
do it forever and get obsessed with
those kinds of comparisons but those
kinds of like where does self-confidence
come from it doesn't drop from the sky
you have to build it and so how are you
going to build it if you never kind of
look around and try to gauge where you
are again it's is that like virtuous no
but is it is it vicious I actually don't
think it's that vicious well this is
something quite important for people who
are interested in virtue ethics
um there's often this tendency
to say if you're going to be a virtue
ethicist or take a virtue ethics
perspective for orienting your life then
virtue has to really be the only thing
that that counts and sometimes they'll
say well you know Aristotle also said
some money and some friends and that's
nice
um but all of this other stuff that's
neither virtuous nor vicious and may
actually be like what the stoics call
the indifference it's at a lower level
of value it really does matter yeah and
it's part of a well integrated or at
least semi-well Integrated Life yeah
yeah and I am I you know I'm I didn't
start out as like a Bernard Williams fan
but I became one sort of as doing this
work okay because I think he's I mean I
think he really has that criticism sort
of right you know I'm a moral
philosopher it's what I do it's the
reason I get out of bed in the morning
but I think moral philosophy especially
when it comes to emotions has this kind
of imperializing tendency right to sort
of look at absolutely every aspect of
your life and try to fit it into this
kind of moral framework and I just think
Williams is flat right about this that
this is not really a way to think about
human life and that we kind of need to
have a bit more of a holistic picture of
human life and not necessarily try we
can talk about values and things that
are important and things that we should
care about that aren't necessarily
undergirded by a kind of moral value or
a moral concern and so that and it took
me a long time to get to that place and
I I'm feeling more comfortable with it
was that the case you know I've I I'm a
kantian like through and through and I
very much
um and like if you like total aside we
can talk about like and I like I think
he's actually a little bit more friendly
to Williams Than People realize but but
there's I get that that's a
controversial interpretation so I'm
going to set that aside
um it did I think when you start writing
when I started my career it was like you
look at the literature and I want to
defend negative emotions I want to talk
about those I think those are
interesting you look at the lit and and
everything in the lit is doing this move
where it's actually this the motion is
in a moral emotion did you know that
it's moral right it's just a different
conception like let's you know widen the
lens and this is what it and so the way
of Defending negative emotions is to say
well it's a negative emotion but it's
still moral right right and I and as I
was writing I was like I don't think
that's the move I want to make like I
actually don't want to turn all of these
things into moral emotions yeah and it
kind of narrows it right it yes it
becomes well
um so let's let's take you know strassen
and resentment and stuff like that well
it's okay because it's serving the whole
purpose but as soon as it stops doing
that right now it's back to being a bad
emotional that's right and that's the
other so I earlier I talked about sort
of bomb kind of view that was you know
you have to transcend transcend
transcend and like this is how you deal
with negative emotions and then I think
there's a really strong a particularly
contemporary philosophy there's a really
strong tendency to say no no no don't
transcend
um but realize the moral importance of
so we're very we're happy to defend a
version of righteous anger we're happy
to defend a version of righteous
contempt we're happy to try to defend a
righteous jealousy or righteous Envy or
whatever and and I'm like no not that
either like that's not so I don't I
don't love transcend but I also don't
like the idea that we can only care
about these emotions and value them when
they're righteous yeah
yeah I mean there's a I'm going to shift
the conversation a bit
um to an area that I know you you know
quite a bit about so ethics of care
right when we're teaching it it's kind
of tricky because it's a little bit
amorphous and it's been developing but
one of the things that I will tell
students is that um you know emotions
wind up being brought back into the the
picture and that you know what we what
we really want to stress is concern or
care or or empathy right right and
people generally view these positively
um but it seems like
um you know we have to be quite careful
with this and there's plenty of
literature out there you don't want to
you don't want to care so much or show
concern so much that you ignore your own
needs and stuff like that right
um but that you know on the one hand you
get the hyper masculine people or I
suppose just people who've like managed
to turn off their emotional life and
they're like this is irrational you must
not be indulging yourself right right
um or or you know that's that's womanly
we don't want that sort of thing I mean
forget the fact that like ancient virtue
ethics talk constantly about emotions
right right
um and then you know on the other hand
we have the people who like well so long
as you're being empathetic even if it's
with somebody who's a terrible person
and wants to you know eat the crap out
of their spouse and you're like taking
in their side and showing them sympathy
and care and all that that's good right
yeah and you want to say no that's you
you know if anybody you should be caring
about the victim not the aggressor you
know yeah yeah there's a different sort
of um that that can get played out in
like a couple different ways there's a
there's this one view that seems to and
I don't know where exactly this comes
from but it's a it's a weird I mean you
don't see it too much in philosophy I
don't think but it it's a kind of
offshoot of Romanticism right which is
to sort of say
um emotions are there's a kind of Purity
that's that's attributed to that okay so
they they are always good and they know
and they're right and there's they're a
kind of like Oracle inside of you that
you should always listen to right and
that sort of and um you know that's not
again that's like way overly Rosy a
picture of our emotional life and that
somehow it's the it's it's almost like
it's a a weird sort of like tractor beam
that's gonna all you know automatically
you know if you just listen to your
sympathy it's going to take you directly
into the right direction and right yeah
it's you're you're I I don't know of
anybody is there anybody in the history
I mean it holds that view like even
people who are very Pro sympathy I feel
like I'm not totally sure that that's
right I mean maybe there's like some
version of so I think you can attribute
that YouTube yeah like a little bit but
even then I feel like it's more
complicated than that but so you see
that but then you also see I think a
kind of like
um
yes there's this like there's this
lionizing of your emotional life in a
way that it it's sort of in the you know
in the in the traditional kind of
sometimes you get feminist philosophers
kind of telling the story of like reason
was king and you know denigrated
emotions and blah blah blah what well
let's don't do the thing where let's
don't just do the opposite right like
let's don't let's don't like hold
emotions up it's not now they're King
and reason's not King and it's like
but there's no King how about we don't
have a king like that's that's the way
we can handle this
yeah and if we want to follow out that
model well then no King who's going to
rule well we need something like a not
necessarily democracy where every single
person gets to say their their thing and
so every weird you know quirky emotion
gets to like come to the the fore but
you know maybe something like
um an aristocratic morality is the model
right there's there's the Bettors and
they may not necessarily be the morally
better but they all get to like say
something and they have like emotions
working for them I mean here we're
getting into like very speculative stuff
yeah yeah yeah right yeah
well I want to be uh respectful of your
time and thanks for giving so much yeah
absolutely um is there anything else
that you want to bring up before we we
uh finish up
no I don't think so I mean I hope uh I
just want to stress again for the folks
who are watching out there that you know
the book the new book is really for it's
for everybody I don't want people to be
intimidated just because it's a
philosophy book I you know it's it's not
no expertise required um I really wanted
it to be welcoming and inviting to
people anybody who wants to think about
their negative emotions you know again
hope the philosophers out there will
will like it but you know I really want
I really wanted it to be sort of for
everyone
well that's excellent so great
conversation thanks so much for thanks
for having me yeah thanks all right